help us understand what happened with
the the this famous g wagon the famous g
wagon did you ever get it back uh
yeah well actually this is some recent
stuff too
i did not this is for the record i did
not sell my uh g wagon for opiates i
never would have done that i used to
have a chauffeur and but he was a good
friend of mine named curly and he would
drive me places if he needed places to
uh he was from my hometown so sometimes
he'd have to drive it back to go see his
parents i'd let him use it and stuff
and um what happened was
uh stats it needed uh maintenance
because those g-wagons are always in the
shop you know what i mean it's i would
never get a g-wagon again so stat said
yo i'm gonna take it in and stack and
stack you're you're my manager my former
manager stack quote so he trick curly
said y'all i'm gonna pay for the
maintenance fixes and he came and took
the car and just never gave it back and
they spun the narrative as if i sold it
for opiates
but what it what the g wagon is now is
we we came to an agreement just to sell
it and split split it uh 50 50. yeah
yeah but i i didn't sell it for opening
that but if i understood correctly you
had put
like all all the money into it i got
[ __ ] over i got [ __ ] over yeah i got
[ __ ] over but
i'm i'm debating whether to take it to
court or just let it slide
um because i did put 120 000 and it was
140 and i was making 800 payments so i
did get [ __ ] over but i i i'm just i
think this is one where i'm just going
to let it live you know what i mean that
i mean
that i can see the logic in that
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at
[Applause]
stevo.com you